now don't judge a book by its cover if  you don't know this gentleman he was on  Rogan  um he's kind of you know for lack of a  better word and kind of a nerdy dude but  straight [ __ ] Savage  Savage will read freaking Lord of the  Rings then snap your neck that's Mikey  dude he's a Savage and he's uh it's dude  what's dope about it is I don't think  jutsu's ever been on this level I'm this  big of a car this mainstream of card  it's a flyweight submission uh grappling  World title fight it'll be a good fight  and their second one which he lost on  points I think it was either 2017 was  like grappling match of the year it was  ridiculous  so it should be dope man should be dope  just to highlight Jiu Jitsu you know  what I'm saying it's a big deal man it's  a big freaking deal